la segunda ola de kobe 19 parece no
llegar a su pico en francia en las
últimas 24 horas el país rompió su
récord y registró 30 mil 621 contagios
las autoridades han informado que hay
1.500 86 focos de contagio
la cifra se conoce previo a que el
sábado entre en vigor el toque de queda
entre las nueve de la noche y las seis
de la mañana decretado en parís y las
otras ocho ciudades más afectadas por la
pandemia
en medio de la crisis cientos de
trabajadores de la salud protestaron en
varias ciudades para exigirle al
gobierno que contrate más personal pues
ya no dan abasto
no tenemos una cama extra desde la
primera ola o fetsyk omitiera ponia de
hecho es como si la primera ola no
hubiera ocurrido así que repetiremos lo
mismo con los mismos problemas en dos
semanas
[Música]
hay mucha rabia entre nosotros y entre
los médicos porque el presidente macro
no hizo promesas pero solo nos dio un
bono
[Música]
y eso no reemplaza la necesidad de
personal en nuestras unidades
entretanto fueron allanadas las
viviendas y oficinas del ministro de
sanidad el director de salud pública y
otros funcionarios
el procedimiento que se desarrolló sin
contratiempos se llevó a cabo como parte
de la investigación que se realiza sobre
la respuesta a la pandemia luego de que
decenas de médicos y autoridades locales
se quejaran del actuar del gobierno
nacional